les vaccins au coeur des discussions
lors du conseil de défense et du conseil
des ministres de ce mercredi reproché
d'avoir un plan de vaccination trop lent
comparé à ses voisins européens
le gouvernement essaie de calmer ses
détracteurs et annonce une augmentation
du nombre de centres de vaccination
élargir les publics ciblés nous avons
d'ailleurs déjà commencé à le faire tous
les soignants de plus de 50 ans peuvent
ainsi d'ores et déjà se faire vacciner
nous allons multiplier le nombre de
centres de proximité pour les soignants
et bientôt pour les personnes âgées de
plus de 75 ans en population générale
ainsi depuis ce matin le nombre
d'hôpitaux pouvant vacciner a été
multiplié par trois et nous allons
ouvrir nous ouvrons centre destiné à la
ville ce n'est qu'un début nous en
ouvrirons 300 la semaine prochaine et
500 celle d'après par la voix de son
porte parole le gouvernement annonce
l'arrivée de cinq cent mille doses du
vaccin files au rebut renntech chaque
semaine alors que la france en possède
un million de doses au 6 janvier
autres thèmes évoqués lors de la rentrée
ministériel les nouvelles mesures
sanitaires pour enrayer l'épidémie
le premier ministre jean castex tiendra
une conférence de presse jeudi à 18h sur
ce sujet en attendant les futures
annonces le monde de la culture mais
également les restaurateurs ne se font
guère d'illusions sur leur réouverture
prévue le 20 janvier et bien aujourd'hui
ce qui est clair c'est qu'on ne va pas
réouvrir le 2 janvier ça c'est pas une
pole man parce qu'on se doutait qu'elle
paraît ouvrir le 20 janvier on n'a pas
de date
aujourd'hui ouverture nous ce qu'on
attend c'est de la visibilité ce qui a
rien de pire que de ne pas savoir ce
qu'on va faire que ce soit dans des
métiers où dans d'autres attaques
personnelles si mouscron luxe et ouvrir
de façon j'oserais dire définitive quand
on va dans une bâtisse et mars et mars
mais c'est pas pour fermer deux semaines
après si la réouverture des remontées
mécaniques à ce jeudi avait été annoncé
en décembre par jean castex le
gouvernement a finalement indiqué
qu'elles resteront à l'arrêt encore
quelque temps dans les stations de ski
l'objectif est désormais de pouvoir
tourner à plein régime lors des vacances
de février